From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And let me do something that I've never done before. Let me just reach out and retune your radio for you.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。让我做一件以前从未做过的事。让我伸出手，为你重新调谐一下收音机。
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
You're on the air at WPLP.
你现在是在WPLP电台的直播节目中。
Good evening, Bob.
晚上好，鲍勃。
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
I'm going to write more than one letter. I'm going to write the station. I'm going to write the chamber of commerce.
我要写的不止一封信。我要写给电台，我要写给商会。
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
--basketball team. I always wanted to go to Miami High--
——篮球队。我一直想去迈阿密高中——
You ever flip through the dial, past the stations that you listen to all the time, just skim up the dial, slowly, from station to station, waiting for something? You don't even know what. Something. Anything.
你有没有试过拨动旋钮，越过那些你常听的电台，只是慢慢地从一个台扫到另一个台，等着听到什么东西？你甚至不知道在等什么。什么都好，什么都行。
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
[SPEAKING INUIT]
[因纽特语对话]
Something like this, a radio signal whose source is impossible to figure out and the intimacy of one voice. What could be more personal, even in another language?
就像这样，一个来源不明的无线电信号，以及一个声音所带来的亲密感。还有什么比这更私人的呢，哪怕是在另一种语言里？
[SPEAKING INUIT] Hello to you, Barney and Rosie. Hello to you, Rose. I'm happy to you-- OK, I'm singing to you Ayatollah Khomeini [SPEAKING INUIT] [BEGINS SINGING]
[因纽特语对话] 你们好，巴尼和罗西。你好，罗斯。我很高兴能……好的，我为你们唱首歌，阿亚图拉·霍梅尼……[开始演唱]
This recording off the radio is one of those things that got recorded and then was passed from person to person to person. Finally, it ended up on a compilation tape of radio moments put together by radio station WFMU in New Jersey. And that's how we got it. By anybody's best guess, it's a radio station in northern Canada. The speaker is Inuit.
这段录制自收音机的录音，是那种被录下来之后又在人与人之间不断传阅的东西。最终，它出现在了新泽西州WFMU电台制作的一盘电台瞬间精选磁带上。我们就是这样得到的。据大家推测，这是一家位于加拿大北部的电台。说话的人是因纽特人。
And here's where it gets a little hazier. Because they're talking about a strike over and over on this tape, it's possible that this is a situation where the regular radio staff is on strike, and these are the replacement workers. Or it's possible that these are the regular workers who are about to go on strike, fed up, at the end of their rope. Or maybe that's not the story at all.
事情到了这里就变得有些模糊了。因为录音里一直在谈论罢工，所以很有可能是常规电台工作人员在罢工，而这些是替补工作人员。或者也有可能是常规工作人员即将罢工，他们受够了，已经到了忍无可忍的地步。又或者，根本就不是那么回事。
That's actually one of the things that I like about this. Like a lot of good radio, part of what is so appealing about it is what it leaves you wondering and thinking about when it's over.
这其实就是我喜欢这段录音的原因之一。像许多优秀的广播节目一样，它之所以吸引人，部分原因在于它留下了让人思考和回味的空间。
[SPEAKING INUIT]
[因纽特语对话]
Can you imagine tuning your radio and stumbling upon this? You know, just stumbling on this? It's so ephemeral, this moment just happening and passing and about to actually evaporate into nothing forever. And that's part of what makes radio different from other media, I think, that quality where it can seem so small and so fleeting.
你能想象调收音机时偶然听到这个吗？就是这么偶然地碰上？它是如此短暂，这一刻正在发生、经过，并且即将永远消失。我认为，这就是广播区别于其他媒体的地方，它那种显得如此渺小而又转瞬即逝的特质。
[SPEAKING INUIT]
[因纽特语对话]
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
Ian Brown used to host the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation show Sunday Morning , and he was very great to listen to. He was smart and unpretentious and this great interviewer and writer. And when the show was revamped and he was taken off the air as host, he read this little radio essay on his last day about the intimacy of radio-- the false intimacy of radio, that feeling that we get together every week, you and me. I mean, literally, that's what it feels like. It feels like you and me. You and me, even though we don't know each other at all.
伊恩·布朗曾是加拿大广播公司《周日早晨》节目的主持人，听他的节目真的很棒。他聪明、不造作，是一位出色的采访者和作家。当节目改版，他不再担任主持人时，他在最后一天读了一篇关于广播亲密感的小短文——那种虚假的亲密感，那种你我每周聚在一起的感觉。我的意思是，字面意思上听起来就是那样。感觉就像是你和我。虽然我们根本不认识，但感觉就像是你和我。
Anyway, months passed after he ended that job, and we wanted to get him on our show-- on This American Life And I called him up, and he was not brusk but businesslike, very proper, formal. And it sounds ridiculous to say-- I feel sort of silly saying it-- but it was hard not to feel a little strange about it. It was hard not to feel a little bit like here is this friend who went suddenly cold.
总之，在他结束那份工作几个月后，我们想请他来我们的节目——《美国生活》。我给他打了电话，他并不唐突，但公事公办，非常得体、正式。说出来可能很荒谬——我甚至觉得有点傻——但很难不为此感到一丝古怪。很难不觉得这就像是一个突然冷淡下来的朋友。
And I would not feel that way about Ted Koppel or Peter Jennings or anybody else who I've ever seen on television. I can tell you that. There is just something about radio. There's just something about radio. It's more personal.
我对泰德·科佩尔、彼得·詹宁斯或我在电视上见过的任何其他人都没有这种感觉。我可以肯定。广播就是有某种东西。广播就是有某种东西。它更私人化。
Well, this is our hundredth episode of This American Life . Each week on our program, we choose a theme, and for our hundredth show, we bring you an hour of stories about the medium in which we work . A program on radio-- what makes it great when it's great, what makes it terrible when it's terrible, which it often is. Act One of our program today, Brigadoon. Searching for an illegal radio station in Miami that keeps appearing and disappearing and appearing again in the mist.
嗯，这是我们的第一百期《美国生活》。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为了第一百期节目，我们为你带来一小时关于我们所从事媒体的故事。一个关于广播的节目——是什么让它在优秀时如此优秀，又是什么让它在糟糕时如此糟糕，而它往往确实很糟糕。我们节目的第一幕，“布里加登”。寻找迈阿密的一个非法广播电台，它不断出现、消失，又在迷雾中重新出现。
Act Two, The Invisible Leading the Blind. Jack Hitt stumbles on a radio station that seems to completely ignore the last six decades of broadcasting style and convention.
第二幕，“隐形人引导盲人”。杰克·希特偶然发现了一个电台，它似乎完全忽略了过去六十年的广播风格和传统。
Act Three, Radio Most People Listen To, an act in which we spend some time with the radio programmers who think that it's better to play the same exact songs over and over all day long, the consultants who make every radio station sound the same. In short, the thinking that makes most radio in America today so boring, and we defend those guys.
第三幕，“大多数人收听的广播”，我们花时间与那些认为最好整天循环播放相同歌曲的广播制作人相处，与那些让每个电台听起来都一样的顾问们相处。简而言之，这种思维让今天美国的大多数广播变得如此乏味，而我们为这些人辩护。
Act Four, Noble Calling. A winner of the Nobel Peace Prize who says that when peace comes to his country of East Timor, he has just one wish. He wants to do a radio show like Howard Stern's. Stay with us.
第四幕，“崇高的使命”。一位诺贝尔和平奖得主说，当和平降临他的祖国东帝汶时，他只有一个愿望。他想做一个像霍华德·斯特恩那样的广播节目。请继续收听。
The following program is furnished by.
以下节目由……赞助提供。
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
Are you married or are you living in sin?
你结婚了吗，还是在苟且？
A little of each.
两者皆有一点。
You blast me, boy. You blast me.
你让我震惊，伙计。你真让我震惊。
Act One, Brigadoon. We're devoting this first half of our program to the ephemeral thrill of stumbling onto some radio station, some radio moment, that you don't know where it came from, and you don't know what it is, but you just cannot stop listening. We have this first story from Iggy Scam in Miami.
第一幕，“布里加登”。我们将节目上半部分专门用于探讨那种偶然发现某个电台、某个广播瞬间的短暂快感，你不知道它来自何处，不知道它是什么，但就是无法停止倾听。我们先从迈阿密的伊基·斯卡姆讲起。
My friend [? Sinclair ?] was the one who first found the Northside black power pirate radio station way down the left of the FM dial. You could only tune it in up on the Northside, so we'd listen to it while we drove down 79th Street whenever I went to his house. You could tell it was pirate radio because of the number of times the DJs would say [BLEEP] in every sentence.
我的朋友[辛克莱？]是第一个在FM波段左侧尽头发现“北区黑人力量”海盗电台的人。你只能在北区收到它，所以每当我开车去他家时，我们都会在70街上听。你能看出那是海盗电台，因为DJ们在每个句子中都会说[消音]的次数。
They'd play all this poorly-recorded local rap, like this one song, "Too Many Suckers and Not Enough Stretchers" where the guy raps, "Living in the M, the I, the A-M-I. Sometimes, I've got to ask myself why." And then they'd play Tupac and then, every couple of beats, the DJs would just cut in over it and just scream, howl, or go "Uh!" And then the music would cut out completely.
他们会播放那些录制得很烂的本地说唱，比如那首《太多傻瓜，没有足够的担架》，歌词唱道：“住在M，I，A-M-I。有时我不得不问自己为什么。”然后他们会播放图派克，每隔几拍，DJ就会切入，尖叫、嚎叫或喊“嘿！”然后音乐完全中断。
Most of the time, there'd be four or five DJs all in the room with the mic, all just talking and yelling and telling jokes over the music. It was totally loud and chaotic and fun. They even took phone calls somehow. They'd play a beat over the radio, and then people would call up to rap over it over the phone. Talk about DIY.
大多数时候，房间里会有四五个DJ对着麦克风，在音乐声中聊天、大喊、讲笑话。这完全是吵闹、混乱且有趣的。他们甚至还能接听电话。他们在广播里播放节奏，然后人们打电话进来在电话里伴着节奏说唱。这才是真正的DIY。
Actually, they were never really that overtly political at all, really. We only called it  the "black power station" because of one time when they were taking calls, and this dude called up and said, check it out, man. Southern Bell van's been parked in front of my house for three days. There ain't nothing wrong with the goddamn phone. It's the white man spying on us and trying to keep us down. Like I said, it was a great station.
其实，他们从来没那么明显的政治化。我们叫它“黑人力量电台”是因为有一次他们接听电话时，有个家伙打电话来说，看看，伙计。南方贝尔公司的车在我家门口停了三天了。电话根本没坏。是白人在监视我们，试图打压我们。就像我说的，那是一个很棒的电台。
Besides being really great radio, the station was exciting. Who were these guys? Where did they broadcast from? And how did everyone in the city know their number to call in when they never gave it out over the air? When the DJs talked, I'd listen to see if there was even some discernible code that they used. I couldn't catch one. I never found out anything about it, really, and eventually, I just moved away from Miami.
除了是真的很棒的广播，这个电台还很刺激。这些人是谁？他们在哪里广播？为什么城里每个人都知道他们接听电话的号码，而他们却从未在广播里公布过？DJ说话时，我试着听听他们是否用了什么可辨认的代码。我一个都没听出来。我没发现任何关于它的信息，最终，我搬离了迈阿密。
But after all my plans fell apart one by one last year, I found myself back in Miami trying to sort it all out. I ended up living back up on the Northside, off 79th Street. Good old 79th Street, home to the "Welcome To Miami" water tower and the INS building. Six lanes of road from beach to swamp, full of rusty, old, American cars blasting bass. The home of the urban trailer park and the indoor flea market, the $0.99 quart of malt liquor.
但在去年的计划接连失败后，我发现自己又回到了迈阿密，试图理清一切。我最终又住回了北区，在79街附近。古老的79街，是“欢迎来到迈阿密”水塔和移民局大楼的所在地。六车道的道路从海滩延伸到沼泽，充满了锈迹斑斑的美国旧车，震耳欲聋。这里有城市拖车公园、室内跳蚤市场，还有99美分的麦芽酒。
I always thought 79th Street, and not the beaches or hotels, is probably the true heart of Miami. You could look at everything and think, this was all once somebody's idea of a good idea. Right away, I started trying to tune in to the station, but I couldn't seem to find it. I didn't know if my radio had bad reception or if they'd just gone off the air. I wasn't even sure of the exact frequency, really. I became sort of obsessed with finding out what happened to those guys, but there was no way to find out.
我一直认为，79街，而不是那些海滩或酒店，才是迈阿密真正的核心。你可以看着这一切心想，这曾经是某人觉得不错的主意。我马上开始尝试调谐到那个台，但我似乎找不到它了。我不知道是我的收音机接收不好，还是他们停播了。我甚至不确定确切频率。我变得有点痴迷于想知道这些人发生了什么，但根本无从知晓。
Meanwhile, I kept busy taking long bike rides to explore the Northside, an almost touching daily tour of the very architecture of defeat. Often, I rode by sad, old Bobby Maduro Stadium, which is named for a Cuban baseball star who had never made the majors. Originally, it had been built in the '50s by a Cuban financier who was trying to lure Major League Baseball into Miami. And even then, he built it way too small for the major leagues.
与此同时，我骑着自行车在北区漫长地探索，这是一场感人的、关于失败建筑的日常巡游。我经常骑车经过悲伤的波比·马杜罗体育场，它是以一位从未进入大联盟的古巴棒球明星命名的。它最初是在50年代由一位古巴金融家建造的，他试图把职业棒球大联盟吸引到迈阿密。即便在当时，他造的球场对于大联盟来说也太小了。
The financier lost all his money eventually, backing Castro, and then later backing anti-Castro revolutionaries. By the 1980s, the stadium was only used as a shelter and processing center for Nicaraguan refugees. And now, it was a host to a weekend flea market in its parking lot.
那位金融家最终赔光了所有钱，因为他资助了卡斯特罗，后来又资助反卡斯特罗革命者。到了80年代，球场只被用作尼加拉瓜难民的收容和处理中心。现在，它的停车场成了周末跳蚤市场的举办地。
Eventually, I pretty much fell in love with the Northside for its own sake, and I gave up the search for the station. But then one time, on my daily ride past the unused warehouses and huge fenced-off lots full of weed and rubble and the boarded-up housing projects, I found what could've been an important clue about the station. Down at the end of a dead-end street where almost certainly no one would see it, someone had spray painted "Tape Radio, 61.5 WEED."
最终，我爱上了北区本身，放弃了寻找电台的念头。但有一次，当我日常骑行经过废弃的仓库、杂草丛生和碎石满地的围栏地块，以及用木板封死的住宅区时，我找到了可能是关于电台的重要线索。在一条死胡同的尽头，几乎肯定没人会看到的地方，有人喷漆写着“Tape Radio, 61.5 WEED”。
Now, 61.5 would seem to be a radio frequency. WEED would seem to be a station's call letters. Was this some kind of ad? How could it be a station, though, if the FM band doesn't even go down that low? Even if there could be a station at 61.5, no one would have a radio that could tune it in. 61.5 would almost certainly be dead air-- static.
61.5看起来像是频率。WEED看起来像是呼号。这是一种广告吗？但如果FM波段根本没那么低，它怎么可能是电台呢？即使61.5能有电台，也没人有能调到那个频率的收音机。61.5几乎可以肯定是空载，只有静电。
I decided to even try it as a phone number--615-WEED. Not in service. I figured that since there's never really any people walking around down there on that dead-end street, if 61.5 was somehow a station, they were probably broadcasting from a warehouse on that very street and that the broadcasters themselves must have painted it. Later that same day, I found the exact same spray painted message in the same exact writing in black paint 30 blocks north in Little Haiti.
我甚至试着把它当作电话号码拨打——615-WEED。无法接通。我想，既然那条死胡同里从没人走动，如果61.5真的是个电台，他们很可能就是在街上的仓库里广播，而且广播员自己肯定涂了这个。那天晚些时候，我在北边30个街区外的小海地发现了同样的喷漆信息，字迹完全一样。
I never did find out what it meant. But that night, it was hot as hell outside-- the beginning of the Miami summer-- and I was just laying around feeling sweaty and miserable when I checked the radio for first time in weeks. And I couldn't believe it. The station was back on the air. DJ Funky One was on, playing music and taking calls. He'd play a little instrumental beat part, and then suddenly cut in completely over the music, put the caller on the air and yell, what's up?
我始终没弄明白是什么意思。但那天晚上，外面热得要命——迈阿密夏天的开始——我正躺着，汗流浃背，痛苦不堪，这时我几周来第一次检查了收音机。我简直不敢相信。电台又开播了。DJ Funky One在直播，放音乐，接电话。他会播放一小段器乐节奏，然后突然盖过音乐，把听众切入电台，大喊“什么事？”
Caller would say, I want to say it two times for Little Haiti. DJ Funky One would say, all right, baby. Little Haiti's in the house. What's up? Next caller wanted to say one time for the Larchmont clique. All right, what's up? One time for Arena Towers, one time for the 6-8, one time for Edison, two times for the 7-4 boys, and a shout out to Shadow Man. It went on all night, music and calls.
听众会说，我想为小海地喊两次。DJ Funky One会说，好的，宝贝。小海地在直播。什么事？下一位听众想为Larchmont帮派喊一次。好的，什么事？为Arena Towers喊一次，为6-8喊一次，为爱迪生喊一次，为7-4男孩喊两次，还要给Shadow Man打个招呼。整晚都在进行，音乐和电话。
Outside my window, the station's signal was flying strong over the dark, rosy streets and avenues, past the open windows and open apartment doors and front porches, and the whole sad city out there sweating in the night. I drank some tall cans from the 79th and Biscayne gas station beer special and listened, and it felt  like every radio in the Northside must be tuned in.
在我窗外，电台的信号强力地飞过黑暗、玫瑰色的街道和大道，越过敞开的窗户和公寓门、前廊，还有那整个在夜色中流汗的悲伤城市。我喝了几罐在79街和比斯坎加油站特价买的啤酒，听着广播，感觉北区的每一台收音机一定都调到了这个台。
Finally, after a while, I heard the phone number actually given out on the air. So one afternoon, when only music was on and they weren't taking calls, I called up anyway. I couldn't believe it when DJ Funky One himself actually answered the phone. I said, "Uh, what are you guys called?"
终于，过了一会儿，我听到他们真的在广播里报出了电话号码。所以一天下午，当只有音乐、他们没接电话时，我还是打了过去。当DJ Funky One本人真的接听电话时，我简直不敢相信。我说：“呃，你们叫什么名字？”
He said, "We're the Space Station."
他说：“我们是空间站。”
"Well, where do you guys broadcast from?"
“那么，你们是在哪里广播的？”
"Carol City."
“卡罗尔城。”
I said, "Do you, like, have a license or anything?"
我说：“你们有执照之类的吗？”
And DJ Funky One started laughing really hard, and he said, "Yeah, yeah. We got all that [BLEEP], man." And then he hung up on me.
DJ Funky One开始大笑，说：“是啊，是啊。我们有那所有的[消音]，伙计。”然后他就挂了我的电话。
Carol City was at the very north end of the county. It had originally been a white, suburban subdivision, but eventually, it was where city planners tried to get the rising black population of the '60s to move to when the city needed new slum land as far away from downtown as possible. These days, it's a seedy, menacing residential sprawl of little homes and gang graffiti known widely as a place where kids from white, suburban subdivisions go to buy drugs.
卡罗尔城位于县的最北端。它最初是白人的郊区住宅区，但最终，当城市需要尽可能远离市中心的新贫民窟用地时，城市规划者试图让60年代不断增长的黑人人口搬到那里。如今，它是一个破败、具有威胁性的住宅区，到处是小房子和帮派涂鸦，广为人知的是，那是白人郊区孩子去买毒品的地方。
I rode up there, but I found no more graffiti clues to the station's whereabouts. Later, with a car radio, I found that you couldn't even get the station that well north of 125th Street, which is about 60 blocks south of Carol City. So I think that DJ Funky One was probably lying about Carol City.
我骑车去了那里，但没找到更多关于电台下落的涂鸦线索。后来，用汽车收音机我发现，在125街以北，也就是卡罗尔城南约60个街区的地方，你甚至收不到这个台。所以我认为DJ Funky One关于卡罗尔城的说法很可能是谎言。
So I started keeping my eyes open for any new clues on my ride home from the more wealthy southern parts of town, where I was working. It was a long ride home but always interesting. When you left downtown for the Northside, it was like crossing over into the flip side of the postcard. You rode out of the pink and blue neon glare of air-conditioned malls and chain stores and gated condos and hotels and skyscrapers into a dark, narrow maze of funky old wood houses, hand-painted signs, and corner stores. The suburbs have the police protection, but the Northside has voodoo.
于是我开始留意线索，在我从城里较富裕的南部下班回家的路上。那是一段漫长的回家路，但总是很有趣。当你离开市中心前往北区时，就像穿越到了明信片的另一面。你离开了粉色和蓝色霓虹闪烁的空调商场、连锁店、封闭式公寓、酒店和摩天大楼，进入了一个黑暗、狭窄的、充满老木房子、手绘招牌和街角商店的迷宫。郊区有警察保护，但北区有巫毒。
Well finally, one day I got a huge clue when the station was apparently having an on-air live promo party. DJ Funky One said, come on down. We've got all this great food down here at Mama's Kitchen. We've got the fried chicken plate for five bucks and Mama's conch dinner for seven bucks. Could it be? DJ Funky One and a pirate radio transmitter live in a restaurant?
好吧，终于有一天，当电台显然在举行现场直播促销派对时，我得到了一个巨大的线索。DJ Funky One说，快下来。我们在Mama's Kitchen有所有这些美味的食物。我们有五美元的炸鸡拼盘和七美元的Mama海螺晚餐。可能是真的吗？DJ Funky One和一个海盗广播发射器就在一家餐厅里？
The address they gave out was only a couple blocks away in the heart of Little Haiti. But when I got there, there was no restaurant at all, just two black dudes on a couch in front of this tiny house cut up into four efficiencies. There was no music anywhere. There was no sign of a transmitter.
他们给出的地址距离小海地的中心只有几个街区。但当我到达那里时，根本没有餐厅，只有两个黑人小伙坐在四户合租的小房子前的沙发上。到处都没有音乐。没有任何发射器的迹象。
I said, "Uh, are you guys with the radio station?" They looked at me like I was crazy and nodded. "This is Mama's Kitchen?" I could smell chicken. They said it was.
我说：“呃，你们是广播电台的人吗？”他们像看疯子一样看着我，点了点头。“这就是Mama's Kitchen？”我能闻到鸡肉味。他们说是。
I said, "But where's DJ Funky One? Where's the station?"
我说：“但是DJ Funky One在哪？电台在哪？”
They broke up laughing, and then one guy said, "Everyone wants to know that."
他们笑得前仰后合，然后一个人说：“每个人都想知道那个。”
So Mama's Kitchen was really just some guy's mom's kitchen. I ended up passing on the conch dinner, and I just bought a frozen cup of Cherry Kool-Aid for a quarter. I took it to my favorite spot by the tracks and sat there with it, laughing in the summer heat. Now that I'd met two people from the station-- or had I?-- the whole thing was even more mysterious.
所以Mama's Kitchen真的只是某个人的妈妈的厨房。我最终没吃海螺晚餐，只花了25美分买了一杯冷冻樱桃酷爱饮料。我把它带到铁轨旁我最喜欢的地方坐下，在夏日的炎热中大笑。既然我见到了电台的两个人——还是说并没有？——整个事情变得更加神秘了。
Well, I guess I don't mind not knowing, and now I'll probably never find out more about the station because now it was time to move away from the Northside. But I had one last Saturday night with the station, one last night of the station sending out the Miami-style bass to be packaged and delivered to the suburbs via 79th Street in a great, rusted 1971 Oldsmobile. One last ride through the ruins and failing streets and bad ideas that talk to you late at night, like radio.
好吧，我想我不介意不知道，现在我也可能永远不会知道关于电台的更多信息了，因为现在是时候搬离北区了。但我度过了与电台的最后一个周六夜晚，电台最后一次发送迈阿密式的贝斯，通过79街的一辆锈迹斑斑的1971年奥兹莫比尔，打包送到郊区。最后一次骑车穿过那些在深夜里和你说话的废墟、失败的街道和糟糕的想法，就像广播一样。
Iggy Scam's story first appeared in his handwritten, self-published zine Scam. Some music during this story was by the Mission Burrito Project in San Francisco, which delivers free, organic, vegan burritos to the homeless one night a week.
伊基·斯卡姆的故事首次出现在他手写、自出版的杂志《Scam》上。故事中的部分音乐来自旧金山的“Mission Burrito Project”，该项目每周一晚为无家可归者运送免费的有机素食卷饼。
--at the Centers for Disease--
——在疾病控制中心——
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
Music from Wayne Shorter, Greg Osby, and--
韦恩·肖特、格雷格·奥斯比和——的音乐
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
Well, assistant city manager Virginia Dolloff resigned on Friday after two weeks of negotiations over severance issues. City manager Brian Martin disclosed that. Martin had asked --
嗯，助理城市经理弗吉尼亚·多洛夫在与遣散费问题进行了两周谈判后，于周五辞职。城市经理布莱恩·马丁披露了这一点。马丁曾要求——
Act Two, The Invisible Leading the Blind. So much radio listening happens in the car. This radio signal is one that our contributing editor Jack Hitt chanced upon on a long drive.
第二幕，“隐形人引导盲人”。太多的广播收听发生在车里。这个无线电信号是我们的特约编辑杰克·希特在一次长途驾驶中偶然发现的。
It was my decision. I don't want to get into it. You hire and fire until you get one that works.
这是我的决定。我不想谈这个。你雇佣和解雇，直到你找到一个能行的人。
Last month, I was cruising the backwoods of Massachusetts on assignment in a rental car. For the longest time, radio wasn't much help in relieving the boredom of interstate travel. After three hours, my finger was numb from jamming the Seek button when the radio suddenly snagged this station. And it was two elderly gentleman reading. It was unlike anything I'd heard all morning, or for that matter, for the last 30 years.
上个月，我在马萨诸塞州的偏远地区出差，开着租来的车。很长一段时间里，收音机对缓解洲际旅行的枯燥并没有太大帮助。三个小时后，当我猛地按下“搜索”键时，收音机突然捕捉到了这个电台。那是两位老先生在朗读。这与我整个上午，或者说过去30年里听到的任何东西都不同。
Well, a good Monday morning to you, and welcome to the March 2 edition of The News, as being read to you by us volunteers, us being Mike--
嗯，周一早上好，欢迎收听3月2日的新闻，由我们志愿者为你朗读，我们是迈克——
That's me.
那是我。
--and yours truly, Gordon, Monday morning hosts here. And we read for the reading disabled or anyone else who would like to listen. And in the background, you're listening to a usually-swinging band playing Beatles music, Ted Heath from London, England. And we'll hear more of Ted on the way out at 12 o'clock. And then, at 11:00, we'll be playing Engelbert Humperdinck.
——还有你们真诚的戈登，周一早上的主持人。我们为阅读障碍者或任何想听的人朗读。在背景里，你们听到的通常是泰德·希思（来自英国伦敦）演奏的摇摆乐队版披头士音乐。我们会在12点结束时听到更多泰德的曲子。然后，在11点，我们将播放恩格尔伯特·洪佩尔丁克的歌。
Nice fellow.
不错的家伙。
Of course, music is not our game here.
当然，音乐不是我们的强项。
No, it isn't.
不，不是。
We just put it in to relieve or give ourselves a break and get us in the mood to read to you, because for the next two hours, we will be reading. You're listening to the Lowell Association for the Blind Talking Information Radio Reading Service coming to you--
我们只是放它来放松一下，让自己处于为你们朗读的状态，因为在接下来的两个小时里，我们将进行朗读。你们现在收听的是洛厄尔盲人协会提供的“谈话信息电台阅读服务”，来到你们——
The service is provided for the reading impaired. Mike and Gordon read items right out of the Lowell Sun , the Nashua Telegram , the Lawrence Eagle-Tribune . They happily lack all the mannered, practiced intonation and attitude of commercial radio. Their keen story selection favors Homeric battles among sewer commissioners and landfill managers or pronouncements from local cranky professors. I knew right away that I had found my escape from Gordon Liddy and Chumbawamba.
这项服务是为阅读障碍者提供的。迈克和戈登直接从《洛厄尔太阳报》、《纳舒厄电报》、《劳伦斯鹰论坛报》上朗读文章。他们愉快地摒弃了商业广播那种矫揉造作、练习过的语调和态度。他们敏锐的故事选择倾向于下水道专员和垃圾填埋场经理之间的荷马史诗般的战斗，或者来自当地脾气古怪的教授的声明。我立刻知道，我已经找到了逃离戈登·利迪和Chumbawamba的出口。
We really stick to local news if we can-- Merrimack Valley news, southern New Hampshire, northern Massachusetts, anywhere within our listening audience. But it's always local news because we feel-- and I think, Mike, you'll agree with me-- they can hear the national and the international news on their regular radios or televisions.
如果可以的话，我们真的只关注本地新闻——梅里马克谷新闻、新罕布什尔州南部、马萨诸塞州北部，任何我们收听范围之内的。但它总是本地新闻，因为我们觉得——我想迈克你会同意我的观点——他们可以在普通的收音机或电视上听到全国和国际新闻。
Yes, I agree.
是的，我同意。
And we're going to get under way with Mike reading from the Nashua Telegraph , today's edition, by the way.
我们要开始了，顺便说一下，迈克将朗读今天的《纳舒厄电报》。
Yes, good morning. And from the University of New Hampshire, the headline here says, "Domestic Assault Researcher Backs Unorthodox Views." Murray Strauss defends his theory that wives assault husbands as often as the reverse.
是的，早上好。来自新罕布什尔大学，这里的头条说：“家庭暴力研究员支持非正统观点”。默里·施特劳斯为他的理论辩护，认为妻子袭击丈夫的频率与反之一样高。
That's Mike, who seems to have naturally married the vocal charms of Lawrence Welk and Howard Cosell. Gordon's the other one, who tends toward a quieter style. In this story, Mike reveals that the official statistics on domestic abuse are flawed because men simply don't report their beatings to police. And Mike explains why.
那是迈克，他似乎天生就融合了劳伦斯·韦尔克和霍华德·科塞尔的嗓音魅力。戈登是另一位，倾向于更安静的风格。在这个故事中，迈克揭示了关于家庭暴力的官方统计数据是有缺陷的，因为男性根本不会向警察报告他们遭受的殴打。迈克解释了原因。
Although both men and women are likely to be ashamed of being hit by a partner, many men are even more ashamed because they feel it shows them to be a wimp, he said.
他说，虽然男人和女人都可能因为被伴侣殴打而感到羞耻，但许多男人感到更加羞耻，因为他们觉得这显示他们是个懦夫。
Every story ends with a touch of banter from the two hosts.
每个故事结束时，两位主持人都会有一点打趣。
You know, Mike, that's never happened to me.
你知道，迈克，这种事从没发生在我身上。
Oh, me neither.
噢，我也没有。
Well, you're married. I'm not. No wife would ever hit me because it would have to be somebody else's wife, and I don't make friends with other people's wives.
嗯，你结婚了。我没有。没有妻子会打我，因为那必须是别人的妻子，而我不跟别人的妻子做朋友。
I can't remember if I've been hit by somebody else.
我不记得我是否被别人打过。
Oh, you can. Come on. That was a very serious story--
噢，你可以。得了吧。那是个非常严肃的故事——
Yes, it was.
是的，它是。
--but we sort of made a little light of it at the end. And we're sort of informal here on our little radio station, and we hope you don't mind it.
——但我们在结尾处稍微轻描淡写了一下。我们在我们的小电台里比较非正式，我们希望你们不介意。
"Informal" is not quite the right word. The right word is "surreal." Even though the readings are as ordinary as anything found in a newspaper-- Dear Abby, the horoscopes-- their intensity makes the listener feel not so much like he's hearing a radio station as living in this place where Mike and Gordon dwell. Even the obits are absorbing.
“非正式”还不太准确。准确的词是“超现实”。尽管朗读的内容和报纸上的任何内容一样普通——亲爱的艾比、星座运势——它们的强度却让听者感觉与其说是在听广播，不如说是生活在这个迈克和戈登居住的地方。即使是讣告也引人入胜。
Eugene R. Goyette of Alfred, Maine. Committal prayers and services will be conducted at 11:00 AM tomorrow in the chapel at Saint Joseph's cemetery in Chelmsford. Mrs. Anna E. [? Leckis-- ?] or Leekis-- [? Kunzler ?] of Lowell, wife of Charles E. [? Kunzler Sr. ?] Calling hours are at the-- no, this is another one. I'm sorry. She's evidently already been buried, Mrs. [? Kunzler. ?]
缅因州阿尔弗雷德的尤金·R·戈耶特。悼念祈祷和服务将于明天上午11点在切尔姆斯福德的圣约瑟夫公墓礼拜堂举行。来自洛厄尔的安娜·E·[莱基斯？]或[昆兹勒？]夫人，查尔斯·E·[昆兹勒高级？]的妻子。吊唁时间在……不，这是另一个。抱歉。她显然已经被埋葬了，[昆兹勒？]夫人。
I could not turn the stories off, whether it was assistant city manager Virginia Dolloff getting fired because she hadn't done enough to stimulate growth along one part of lower Middlesex Street, or sewer commissioner Tom Moran who, now a candidate for selectman, was worried that his sewer experience might peg him as a one-issue politician, or the account of Representative [? Millnozzle ?] breaking his leg.
我无法关掉这些故事，无论是助理城市经理弗吉尼亚·多洛夫因为没有做足够多的工作来刺激下米德尔塞克斯街一部分的发展而被解雇，还是下水道专员汤姆·莫兰（现在是行政委员候选人）担心他的下水道经验可能使他被贴上单议题政治家的标签，或者是关于[米尔诺兹尔？]议员摔断腿的报道。
But the story that had me spellbound for 10 minutes was a long and treacherous account of the annual meeting of the Dracut Water Supply District. It was rich in character and subterfuge, a mini Shakespearean drama. Essentially, three board members who faced pay cuts had packed the meeting with relatives. And in the end, they GOT raises.
但让我着迷了10分钟的故事是关于Dracut供水区年度会议的一场漫长而危险的叙述。它充满了性格和诡计，是一出迷你莎士比亚戏剧。本质上，三名面临减薪的董事会成员用亲戚填满了会议现场。最终，他们加薪了。
Graham's relatives at the meeting included his wife and about 10 brothers, sisters-in-laws, cousins, and nephews. Also present were about 15 Graham friends, neighbors, and business associates. Blatus had about 10 relatives at the meeting-- three sons, a sister, a brother, a cousin, and in-laws. [? Annis's ?] wife, daughter, son, and son-in-law were there, as were several of his neighbors. In all, counting relatives and friends of the commissioners, Blatus and [? Gardette ?], totalled close to 100.
格雷厄姆在会议上的亲戚包括他的妻子和大约10个兄弟、嫂子、堂兄和侄子。在场的还有大约15个格雷厄姆的朋友、邻居和商业伙伴。Blatus在会议上有大约10个亲戚——三个儿子、一个姐姐、一个兄弟、一个堂兄和姻亲。[Annis的？]妻子、女儿、儿子和女婿都在那里，还有几个邻居。总的来说，算上专员、Blatus和[Gardette？]的亲戚和朋友，总数接近100人。
But wait, there's more.
等等，还有更多。
26 from the school department, six firefighters, three police officers, and two from the sewer department.
26个来自学校部门，六个消防员，三个警察，两个来自下水道部门。
The disputed raise, by the way, was a mere $2,000. But the ferocity of the battle was apparent, and even the political tactics were strangely familiar. Like Bill Clinton or Newt Gingrich, the raise plotters pretended to be astonished that anyone would question their motives for going to the meeting. So they shrouded themselves in patriotism.
顺便说一下，争议的加薪只有2000美元。但斗争的激烈程度显而易见，甚至政治策略都出奇地熟悉。就像比尔·克林顿或纽特·金里奇一样，加薪策划者假装对任何人质疑他们去开会的动机感到惊讶。于是他们披上了爱国主义的外衣。
"It's just one of those things that happens," said district clerk Michael Blatus. "Everybody can go to a meeting. Shame on the people who don't--
“这只是发生的事情之一，”地区职员迈克尔·布拉图斯说。“每个人都可以去开会。那些不去的人真该感到羞耻——
By the end of the piece, my heart went out to Maureen [? Cares, ?] who had arrived innocently ready to defend smaller Jeffersonian government. But she was easily crushed.
节目快结束时，我为莫琳·[凯尔斯？]感到同情，她天真地赶来准备捍卫杰斐逊式的缩小政府。但她很容易就被压垮了。
"I'm disappointed," said Maureen [? Cares, ?] who attended with her husband. "This was my first water district meeting, and it strikes me as though the other side-- and I hate to use that tern-- it appears that there were some efforts to bring out a particular constituency." Mike?
“我很失望，”莫琳·[凯尔斯？]说，她和丈夫一起来的。“这是我第一次参加水区会议，给我的感觉是对方——我讨厌用那个词——似乎有人努力带出特定的选民。”迈克？
I think that should have been subtitled "All in the Family." And now, I'd like to introduce Lowell's weather wizard, Steve Roberts.
我认为那应该加上字幕“一家人”。现在，我想介绍洛厄尔的天气巫师，史蒂夫·罗伯茨。
The core audience of this program is maybe 200 blind people in New England who actually hear the broadcast on special radios configured to receive its non-AM/FM signal. Occasionally, they air the show on the local college channel, which is how I heard it. But for the most part, Mike and Gordon's universe shares in our air space but is not of it. It's what Lake Wobegon would be if real people lived there, and then broadcast their own show without Garrison Keillor. In this alternate universe, the men are not always strong. Rather, they are savagely beaten by their wives. And the children are not at all above average.
这个节目的核心受众也许是新英格兰的200名盲人，他们实际上是在配置为接收其非AM/FM信号的特殊收音机上听到广播的。他们偶尔会在当地大学频道播出这个节目，这就是我听到它的方式。但大多数情况下，迈克和戈登的宇宙共享我们的空域，却不属于它。如果那里住着真实的人，并且在没有加里森·基勒的情况下广播他们自己的节目，那它就是“沃比根湖”的样子。在这个替代宇宙中，男人们并不总是强大的。相反，他们经常被妻子野蛮殴打。而孩子们根本不是平均水平以上的。
From Tyngsboro, sophomores at three area technical high schools scored poorly last year on a nationwide test of English, math, and other key subjects. Greater Lowell sophomores scored in the 27th percentile, meaning 73% of the school systems nationwide scored higher.
来自泰恩斯伯勒，三所地区技术高中的二年级学生去年在全国英语、数学和其他关键科目的测试中得分很低。大洛厄尔二年级学生得分在第27百分位，这意味着全国73%的学校系统得分更高。
Not that there isn't a good deal of Keillor's sweetness on the air. Mike and Gordon discuss a pledge drive that will occur between now and the-- I'm not making this up-- Acme Club picnic. Later, there's a discussion of the election of the town hog reeve. That's the guy charged with rounding up the village's pigs if they bust out of the pens.
并不是说广播里没有基勒那种甜味。迈克和戈登讨论了一个在现在到——我没编——Acme俱乐部野餐之间进行的认捐活动。后来，还有关于选举镇养猪官的讨论。那是负责在村里的猪冲出围栏时把它们抓回来的家伙。
When you hear this program, you realize just how homogenized everything else on radio is. This is banter that hasn't been focus grouped or copied from another show with better ratings. Finding Mike and Gordon was like discovering radio as it might have been 65 years ago, a kind of ur-radio, beautifully preserved in amber.
当你听到这个节目时，你会意识到收音机上的其他一切是多么的同质化。这是一种没有经过焦点小组测试，也没有从其他收视率更好的节目中抄袭而来的闲聊。发现迈克和戈登就像发现了65年前的收音机，一种被美丽地保存在琥珀中的原始收音机。
By the way, I have a little funny I want to make. Is El Nino related to that old movie star Sal Mineo?
顺便说一下，我有一个小笑话想讲。埃尔尼诺（El Nino）和那个老电影明星萨尔·米内奥（Sal Mineo）有关吗？
No, I don't think so.
不，我不这么认为。
I had to say that. I just had to say that.
我不得不这么说。我只是不得不这么说。
Well, that's all right. I'll ask Dutch. He's an aficionado of these things.
好吧，没关系。我会问达奇。他是这方面的爱好者。
Sal Mineo, eh? OK, Steve, thanks a lot.
萨尔·米内奥，呃？好的，史蒂夫，非常感谢。
You're welcome.
不客气。
Back to the news, we are.
我们回到新闻中来。
Jack Hitt listens to the radio from his home in New Haven, Connecticut. Coming up in the second half of our program, we move from the radio we love to the radio that actually exists on most radio stations, plus, the Nobel Peace Prize winner who wants to host a radio show like Howard Stern's. And which Nobel Peace recipient is it? Nelson Mandela? Henry Kissinger? Yasser Arafat? The Dalai Lama? Real answers in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
杰克·希特在康涅狄格州纽黑文的家中收听广播。在我们节目的后半部分，我们从我们热爱的广播转向大多数电台实际存在的广播，此外，还有想要主持像霍华德·斯特恩那样广播节目的诺贝尔和平奖得主。哪位诺贝尔和平奖得主？纳尔逊·曼德拉？亨利·基辛格？亚西尔·阿拉法特？达赖喇嘛？我们的节目继续，国际公共广播电台为你揭晓答案。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Radio. What makes it so great? What makes it so terrible? And we have arrived at Act Three, The Radio Most People Listen To.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“广播”。是什么让它如此伟大？又是什么让它如此糟糕？我们已经来到第三幕，“大多数人收听的广播”。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He can't even get it out.
他甚至说不出来。
We start June 26.
我们6月26日开始。
Free tickets?
免费门票？
Myra, please.
迈拉，拜托。
Well, I just thought I'd ask.
好吧，我只是想问问。
Not for you.
不是给你的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is a recording of V103, WVAZ in Chicago. A few years back, V103 was in fourth or fifth place. But radio is not an art, my friend. No, no no. It's a science. And by applying scientific principles, consultant Tony Gray and program director Max Myrick transformed V103 until it tied for number one in the Chicago market, year after year, with adults age 25 to 54. This, of course, means lots more ad revenue, much bigger profits. Twice as many adults listen to them as listen to Chicago's public radio station.
这是芝加哥V103电台（WVAZ）的录音。几年前，V103排在第四或第五位。但广播不是艺术，我的朋友。不，不，不。这是一门科学。通过应用科学原理，顾问托尼·格雷和节目总监麦克斯·迈里克改变了V103，使其年复一年地在芝加哥市场中与25至54岁的成年听众并列第一。当然，这意味着更多的广告收入，大得多的利润。收听他们的成年人数量是收听芝加哥公共电台的两倍。
The story of how Max and Tony did this, made their station number one, is the story of how radio works-- pretty much every commercial station on the dial. This is the science of modern radio. And it begins here, 15 blocks away from the radio station.
麦克斯和托尼如何做到这一点、如何使他们的电台排名第一的故事，就是广播运作的故事——波段上的几乎每一个商业电台都是这样。这是现代广播的科学。它始于这里，距离电台15个街区的地方。
These are the offices of a company that V103 hires called Strategic Media Research. Every day, young women in 10 windowless rooms get on the phone in the late afternoon and early evening and call radio listeners. It's targeted research. For V103, they only call the listeners that V103 wants more than any others. These are 35- to 44-year-old African-American women. They go for women rather than for men for a very simple reason, Tony Gray tells me. Women are more likely to actually fill out the Arbitron diaries, which ratings are based on.
这些是一家名为“战略媒体研究”的公司的办公室，V103聘请了他们。每天下午晚些时候和傍晚，10个无窗房间里的年轻女性会打电话给广播听众。这是有针对性的研究。对于V103，他们只拨打V103最想要的那些听众。这些是35至44岁的非洲裔美国女性。托尼·格雷告诉我，他们选择女性而不是男性有一个非常简单的原因。女性更有可能真正填好Arbitron日记，而收视率正是基于此。
In most cases across the country, the stations target females because you know you can rely on the women to fill out the diaries.
在全国大多数情况下，电台都瞄准女性，因为你知道你可以信赖女性会填好日记。
So they get these women on the phone, and they hook them up to a computer which plays them brief clips of 30 different songs over the phone. It takes about 15 minutes. For each song, the women press numbers on the phone's keypad to indicate if they're familiar with the song, how much they like the song, and if they're getting bored of the song, which Max says is the most important thing.
所以他们让这些女性在电话里，并把她们连接到一台电脑上，通过电话给她们播放30首不同歌曲的简短片段。大约需要15分钟。对于每一首歌，女性在电话键盘上按数字来表明她们是否熟悉这首歌，她们有多喜欢这首歌，以及她们是否对这首歌感到厌倦，麦克斯说这是最重要的事情。
Once you get a record on the air, you have to know when to take it off, because there's nothing that'll drive a person away from a station than a song that they're just tired of.
一旦你把一张唱片放到广播里，你就必须知道什么时候把它撤下来，因为没有什么比一首让人厌倦的歌更能把人赶走。
Every week, a printout of the audience scores arrives on Max's desk. And he marks it up, dividing the songs into A songs, B songs, C songs. A songs will be played on V103 every three and a half hours. B songs will be played every five hours. Cs will be played twice a day. These 30 songs are the only new songs that V103 plays They make up 40% of the music on the station.
每周，一份听众评分的打印件都会送到麦克斯的桌上。他会做标记，把歌曲分为A级歌、B级歌、C级歌。A级歌将在V103上每三半小时播放一次。B级歌每五小时播放一次。C级歌每天播放两次。这30首歌是V103播放的仅有的新歌，它们构成了电台音乐的40%。
The other 60% is what radio programmers call "golds," proven songs that always test well with the target audience. For V103, that means Marvin Gaye's "Sexual Healing," anything by Anita Baker. On last week's list, Max crossed off six songs that just did not test well enough to stay on the station, one of them a sentimental favorite for Max by his favorite artist, an artist that he does not want me to name on the radio. So I'll just say that he's a crossover black artist who married Lisa Marie Presley.
其余的60%是广播制作人所说的“黄金曲目”，即那些在目标受众中总是测试良好的成熟歌曲。对于V103，这意味着马文·盖伊的《性疗法》，安妮塔·贝克的任何作品。在上周的列表中，麦克斯划掉了六首测试结果不够好而无法留在电台的歌，其中一首是麦克斯最喜欢的艺术家的感性作品，但他不想让我在广播中说出这个艺术家的名字。所以我只会说他是一位与莉萨·玛丽·普莱斯利结婚的跨界黑人艺术家。
The reason this song is in brackets is because we've been playing it for several weeks. So it's saying it'll never be a hit. The research is saying it's not going to happen.
这首歌之所以在括号里，是因为我们已经播放它几周了。所以它是在说它永远不会成为热门歌曲。研究说这不会发生。
Now, you like this song.
现在，你喜欢这首歌。
I love this song. I love the artist.
我喜欢这首歌。我喜欢这位艺术家。
But you cannot let those feelings interfere.
但你不能让那些感觉干扰你。
No, it's not about me. It's about listeners. It's about playing what they want.
不，这不是关于我。这是关于听众。这是关于播放他们想要的东西。
You have your own radio station here. You can play whatever you want.
你在这里有你自己的广播电台。你可以播放任何你想播放的东西。
That's my job. You said the most important thing. I have my own radio station at home. And I play all the stuff I want to play as often as I want to play it. I make tapes. But when I come here, it's about business-- big business. Millions of dollars are affected by the decisions we make. So that's the real bottom line.
那是我的工作。你说了最重要的一点。我在家有我自己的广播电台。我播放所有我想播放的东西，想放多久就放多久。我制作磁带。但当我来到这里，这是生意——大生意。数百万美元受到我们所做决定的影响。所以这才是真正的底线。
V103 has four competitors who are going after the same demographic group that they are. The average person, says Max, jumps around between two and three radio stations all the time. If at any moment V103 has a song that scores lower with the audience and one of its competitors has a song that scores higher, V103 loses.
V103有四个竞争对手在追求和他们一样的目标群体。麦克斯说，普通人一直在两三个电台之间跳来跳去。如果V103在任何时候有一首歌在听众中的得分较低，而其中一个竞争对手有一首歌得分较高，V103就会输。
Some programming tidbits I picked up during my visit to V103-- if you play rap music, you pretty much say goodbye to any adult audience. So even stations that target African-Americans usually don't play much rap. V103 plays none. Sampling is another matter. One of the reasons that sampling bits of old songs so popular now in pop music has to do with the way that radio stations operate, with the science of modern radio.
我在参观V103时学到了一些编程小知识——如果你播放说唱音乐，你基本上可以告别任何成人受众。所以即使是以非洲裔美国人为目标的电台通常也不会播放太多说唱。V103根本不播放。采样是另一回事。现在流行音乐中采样老歌片段之所以如此流行，与广播电台运作的方式、现代广播的科学有关。
Picture-- if you were a songwriter and you put some famous old clip from a pop song into your song, when radio stations do those telephone surveys of listeners, way more listeners, especially older listeners, are likely to say that they recognize and like your song. And radio stations will add your song to the playlist. One of the songs that Max is adding is a song called "Too Close," which has a sample in it.
想象一下——如果你是一位作曲家，并在你的歌中放入一些著名的老流行歌曲片段，当广播电台进行那些听众电话调查时，更多的听众，特别是老听众，更有可能说他们认出并喜欢你的歌。广播电台就会把你的歌加入播放列表。麦克斯正在增加的一首歌是一首名为《Too Close》的歌，里面有一个采样。
Oh, here it is. This is another song we were looking at. Normally, we would not go on a song like this because it tends to be a little young. But the bed for the song is from a familiar adult song.
噢，在这里。这是我们正在看的另一首歌。通常，我们不会选择这样的歌，因为它往往有点年轻。但这首歌的底基来自一首熟悉的成人歌曲。
What's the sample that they steal-- use?
他们窃取——使用的是什么采样？
What is that song?
那是什么歌？
You'd have to put it in.
你得把它放进去。
Oh, here you go. It was a rap song back in-- oh, "Christmas Rappin'" by Kurtis Blow.
噢，给你。这是一首说唱歌曲，在——噢，库尔蒂斯·布洛的《圣诞说唱》。
Kurtis Blow. Right.
库尔蒂斯·布洛。对。
Remember that?
记得那个吗？
The '80s, sure.
80年代，当然。
This is a very familiar sound. If you're in the adult demo, it's not going to make you mad to hear this song because it's just so familiar. You know this song? What is this song?
这是一个非常熟悉的声音。如果你在成人样本群里，听到这首歌不会让你生气，因为它太熟悉了。你知道这首歌吗？这是什么歌？
When they came to V103, Max and Tony made some changes in personnel, they tinkered with the station's slogans and promotions. They paid a marketing firm to call 200,000 women on the phone telling them to listen for a contest on V103. But the main thing, Tony says, the single most important thing that moved them from number five to tied for first place was picking their music more carefully, letting in nothing that did not test well with the target demographic.
当他们来到V103时，麦克斯和托尼在人事上做了一些变动，他们调整了电台的口号和推广活动。他们付钱给一家营销公司，给20万名女性打电话，告诉她们收听V103的比赛。但主要的事情，托尼说，从第五名提升到并列第一的最重要的一件事是更仔细地选择他们的音乐，不让任何在目标人群中测试不好的歌进入。
A higher degree of discipline. And what, again, my experience has been, a short playlist always seems to fix the problem a lot quicker than, let's say, a more liberal playlist.
更高的纪律性。而且，我的经验再次表明，短播放列表似乎比，比如说，更自由的播放列表能更快地解决问题。
When I went to visit V103, I had not been in a commercial radio station for 20 years. And I was curious about what it was going to be like, Chicago's number one station. Turns out it looks exactly like Chicago's public radio station-- same carpet, same fixtures, same office equipment, same phone system. It looked exactly the same, except everyone at V103 had much nicer clothes. And the stereo speakers in Max's office are nicer than the ones in the studio that I speak to you from right now.
当我去参观V103时，我已经20年没有进过商业广播电台了。我很好奇芝加哥第一电台会是什么样子。事实证明，它看起来和芝加哥的公共广播电台一模一样——同样的地毯，同样的固定装置，同样的办公设备，同样的电话系统。看起来完全一样，除了V103的每个人都穿得好得多。而且麦克斯办公室里的立体声扬声器比我现在正对你们说话的演播室里的扬声器更好。
Tony and Max and I are the same age-- 39 and 40. All three of us started in radio as teenagers Ask them what they love about radio, and they talk about finding unknown songs, putting them on the air, watching them become hits. They talk about the satisfaction of watching the science of radio marketing actually work. And their lives are organized around one moment that happens every month-- the moment they get their numbers.
托尼、麦克斯和我同龄——39岁和40岁。我们三个人都是十几岁时就开始从事广播了。问问他们喜欢广播什么，他们会谈论寻找未知的歌曲，放到广播里，看着它们成为热门。他们谈论看着广播营销科学实际工作的满足感。他们的生活围绕着每个月发生的一个时刻——他们拿到数字的时刻。
It happens every month. I can't sleep the night before the book comes out. I can't do it. I can't sleep. I can't do it. And when I pull them up, I always have my head down. I don't even want to see them. And luckily, we've been at the top of the page. But man--
这每个月都会发生。书出来的头天晚上我睡不着。我做不到。我睡不着。我做不到。当我把它们拉出来时，我总是低着头。我甚至不想看它们。幸运的是，我们一直在页面的顶部。但是，伙计——
Running a station the scientific way means, of course, that most radio stations sound the same. It's why most radio is so boring, why we hear the same songs repeated over and over, everywhere on the dial, from city to city, why V103 can't even play Otis Redding. I should note that public radio does not stand above all this. Research has been driving it for years. The jazz played on Chicago's public radio station is audience tested. The classical musical on most stations is audience tested. The most any of us can hope for in this environment is pockets of individuality.
以科学的方式经营电台，当然意味着大多数广播电台听起来都一样。这就是为什么大多数广播如此乏味，为什么我们在波段上的每个地方、从一个城市到另一个城市都在反复听到同样的歌，为什么V103甚至不能播放奥蒂斯·雷丁。我应该指出，公共广播并没有置身事外。研究多年来一直在推动它。芝加哥公共广播电台播放的爵士乐是经过听众测试的。大多数电台的古典音乐也是经过听众测试的。我们在这个环境中能期望的最多就是一些个性的口袋。
And one of the interesting things about V103 is that their format does include pockets of individuality, most notably, the morning show. Tom Joyner, who's syndicated around the country, who does one of the most idiosyncratic, funny, truly interesting radio shows I have ever heard. It jumps quickly from This Day in Black History to the three-minute radio soap opera It's Your World . From serious and semi-serious to straight-out comedy, it is surprising and just great by any measure.
V103的一个有趣之处在于他们的格式确实包括了个性的口袋，最著名的是早间节目。汤姆·乔伊纳，他在全国范围内联合播出，他做的是我听过的最有个性、最有趣、真正有趣的广播节目之一。它迅速从“黑人历史的今天”跳到三分钟的广播肥皂剧《It's Your World》。从严肃到半严肃，再到直接的喜剧，它令人惊讶，以任何标准衡量都是伟大的。
So we kind of made a little noise, huh, Mr. Novak?
所以我们制造了一些噪音，是吗，诺瓦克先生？
Indeed you did. You've got some power, I would say.
你确实做到了。我可以说，你有一些力量。
No. No, no, the people, not me.
不。不，不，是人们，不是我。
The people, OK.
人们，好的。
It's not me.
不是我。
A few weeks ago, Joyner and his morning crew took on conservative columnist Robert Novak. This is while President Clinton was in Africa apologizing for slavery. Novak, at the time, said something on television about how African-Americans would not be in the United States if not for slavery. Joyner's show started a barrage of mail to the Chicago newspaper that publishes Novak's syndicated column. And very, very quickly, Novak came onto Joyner's show to try to clarify his position for Joyner's audience.
几周前，乔伊纳和他的早间团队与保守派专栏作家罗伯特·诺瓦克较上了劲。当时克林顿总统正在非洲为奴隶制道歉。当时诺瓦克在电视上说了一些关于如果不是因为奴隶制，非洲裔美国人就不会在美国的话。乔伊纳的节目开始向出版诺瓦克联合专栏的芝加哥报纸发送大量邮件。而且非常非常快地，诺瓦克上了乔伊纳的节目，试图为乔伊纳的听众澄清他的立场。
Some of our really fine citizens are African-Americans-- in government, in business, athletics and show business. You know how they got here? They were all slaves, weren't they? So it's kind of a problem. We wouldn't have this enrichment of our society if it wasn't for slavery. I never said slavery was a good thing. I said it was an unusual thing.
我们一些非常优秀的公民是非洲裔美国人——在政府、商业、体育和演艺界。你知道他们是怎么到这里的吗？他们都是奴隶，不是吗？所以这有点问题。如果不是因为奴隶制，我们就不会有这种社会丰富。我从没说过奴隶制是一件好事。我说它是一件不同寻常的事情。
Mr. Novak, let me jump in right quick, if I may. When you say it's kind of a problem, the "it's" in that sentence presumably stands for slavery. So if slavery is kind of a problem--
诺瓦克先生，如果可以的话，让我很快插一句。当你说是“有点问题”时，那个句子里的“它”大概代表奴隶制。所以如果奴隶制有点问题——
No, I didn't mean that.
不，我不是那个意思。
OK, what did you mean by that?
好的，你是什么意思？
I meant it's a logical problem that we wouldn't have--
我的意思是如果不是因为——这是一个逻辑问题。
One more thing about the scientific way of making radio-- it is weirdly democratic. Every song is chosen by polling. Here's this multimillion dollar business, all these well-groomed men and women and their expensive clothes spending every hour of every day thinking about how to please middle-aged, inner-city black women. How many other civic institutions are doing that?
关于制作广播的科学方法还有一点——它奇怪地民主。每一首歌都是通过民意调查选择的。这是价值数百万美元的生意，所有这些穿着考究的男人和女人以及他们昂贵的衣服，每时每刻都在思考如何取悦中产阶级的市中心黑人女性。还有多少其他公民机构在这样做？
And let me just say one thing, that I'm not in the business of offending people. And I am genuinely sorry if anybody was offended by the remarks I made before or even the remarks I made this morning.
让我说一件事，我不做冒犯人的生意。如果我之前发表的言论或甚至我今天早上发表的言论冒犯了任何人，我真的表示抱歉。
OK. We appreciate it. Thank you, Mr. Novak. All right. You've got it. CNN, Washington bureau.
好的。我们很感激。谢谢你，诺瓦克先生。好的。你做到了。CNN，华盛顿分社。
Well, of course, the science of radio-- the machine of modern radio-- takes as well as it gives. It breaks hearts. Lots of people and ideas get knocked off the air as programmers try things they think will more predictably and scientifically attract listeners. Ida Hakkila had a job as a DJ on two big New York rock stations, and she got pushed out for more predictable programming. She began at a station called Z-Rock.
嗯，当然，广播的科学——现代广播的机器——给予的同时也在索取。它让人心碎。随着制作人尝试他们认为能更可预测和科学地吸引听众的事情，很多人和想法被赶出了广播。艾达·哈基拉曾在纽约两个大型摇滚电台担任DJ，但为了更可预测的节目，她被挤了出去。她在一个叫Z-Rock的电台开始工作。
I was the voice of Z-Rock. And what they'd have me do was-- I was kind of younger. I don't think I'd do it now. But I was the only female voice on the station. So I had to be really, really angry, which isn't the way that I am, personally. So it'd be like, AM 1480 Z-Rock! you know, like I was going to hurt somebody. So sometimes--
我是Z-Rock的声音。他们让我做的是——我当时有点年轻。我不认为我现在会这么做。但我当时是电台里唯一的女性声音。所以我必须非常非常愤怒，这与我个人的性格不符。所以听起来就像是，AM 1480 Z-Rock！你知道，就像我要伤害某人一样。所以有时——
And were those instructions to you? Did they actually sit with you in the studio and they're like, "No, angrier. Make it sound angrier"?
那些是对你的指示吗？他们真的在演播室里和你坐在一起，然后说，“不，更愤怒。让它听起来更愤怒”？
No. Actually, I did all the production. I just did everything. It was funny. And I think I got paid, like, $5 an hour. And then, at the end of the day, there was a boss that would hear everything. And he'd say, "Could you sound more, I don't know, like a dominatrix?"
不。事实上，所有的制作都是我做的。我只是做了一切。这很有趣。我想我当时每小时挣5美元。然后，在一天结束时，有一个老板会听到一切。他说，“你能听起来更，我不知道，像个女施虐狂吗？”
And at some point, you became a DJ-- a regular DJ on the station, right?
在某个时候，你成了DJ——电台的常规DJ，对吧？
Right. Well, what happened was, they started out this butt rock rock station. It was called Q104.3.
对。好吧，发生的事情是，他们开始了那个屁摇滚电台。它叫Q104.3。
What are you calling it?
你叫它什么？
Butt rock.
屁摇滚。
Butt rock?
屁摇滚？
And I mean that in the most endearing way. I really love the music. It was AC/DC and Ozzy. And for some reason, the best way to describe it would be to call it butt rock. And the way commercial radio is, there's these very slight parameters.
我是以最令人喜爱的方式说的。我真的很喜欢那音乐。那是AC/DC和Ozzy。不知为何，形容它的最好方式就是叫它屁摇滚。而在商业广播里，有这些非常轻微的参数。
But this guy, as program director, knew that the best thing to do with me was to let me go. The very first shifts that I did were Saturday nights. He'd let me play some of my own records, which was an amazing amount of freedom. I know it doesn't sound like very much, but it was enough space to be a human and to have a lot of fun with the listeners.
但这个家伙作为节目总监，知道对我最好的办法是放手。我做的第一班岗是周六晚上。他让我播放一些我自己的唱片，这给了我惊人的自由。我知道这听起来并不多，但它有足够的空间让我成为一个人，并与听众玩得很开心。
So what happened? So how come you're not there?
那么发生了什么？所以你为什么不在那里了？
Oh, because in 1996, I guess Viacom could own more than one station, and they decided that they wanted to have a station that appealed to males age 25 to 54. So they changed the format from pure rock, which is what they called it, to classic rock.
噢，因为在1996年，我想维亚康姆可以拥有一个以上的电台，他们决定他们想拥有一个吸引25到54岁男性的电台。所以他们把格式从纯摇滚（那是他们叫它的方式）改为了经典摇滚。
These distinctions you're making-- pure rock versus classic rock versus new rock-- it's so Talmudic. It's just so fine.
你做的这些区分——纯摇滚、经典摇滚、新摇滚——太塔木德化了。它太细了。
Classic rock, oh, it was like Aqualung again, and, like, Jimmy Buffett and stuff that just-- I was literally praying to get fired when I kind of saw the writing on the wall. I walked into the promotions closet, and I saw these Jimmy Buffett t-shirts. And I said, OK, I don't want to work here anymore. I hope they fire me.
经典摇滚，噢，那感觉又是《Aqualung》，还有像吉米·巴菲特之类的东西，那简直——当我看到墙上的字时，我真的在祈祷被解雇。我走进促销衣柜，看到了这些吉米·巴菲特的T恤。我说，好的，我不想在这里工作了。我希望他们解雇我。
That's the sign that the Antichrist has arrived-- the Jimmy Buffett t-shirts.
那是反基督者到来的标志——吉米·巴菲特的T恤。
That's exactly it.
正是那样。
Ida turned in her resignation. Then she looked for other jobs, including one at her first radio stations-- Z-Rock and K-Rock. But she decided she couldn't work there when she saw what those jobs would be.
艾达辞职了。然后她寻找其他工作，包括她第一家电台——Z-Rock和K-Rock的工作。但当她看到那些工作会是什么样子时，她决定她不能在那里工作。
And I just kind of knew what was going to happen to me was that they'd want me to become somebody that said what they wanted me to say. You know those-- they're called liners in commercial radio, where DJs say stuff like, keep your button set on us.
我只是有点知道我会发生什么，那就是他们会想让我成为一个说他们想让我说的话的人。你知道那些——在商业广播里它们叫衬词，DJ们会说像“保持你的按钮设置在我们这里”之类的话。
Wow. I didn't know there was a name for that.
哇。我不知道那有个名字。
Yeah, that's called a liner, where they say, like, 20 songs in a row or your money back. Stuff like that. So really, like, middle of the road-- and these were people who were actually-- maybe 10 years before, they were the most vital and vibrant DJs, and they had just been beaten. They were people who were just absolutely beaten. They were reduced to having to say-- I just remember that button one, like, keep your button locked on us. And every day is a no-repeat day. And, we play 20 songs or someone wins $20,000.
是的，那叫衬词，他们会说，像连续20首歌或退还你的钱。之类的东西。所以真的，就像中间道路——这些人实际上是——也许10年前，他们是最重要、最有活力的DJ，而他们刚刚被击败了。他们是被绝对击败的人。他们沦落到必须说——我只是记得那个按钮一，就像，保持你的按钮锁在我们这里。每一天都是无重复的一天。而且，我们播放20首歌或者有人赢2万美元。
And, Ida, literally, what would be in front of you as you were on the air? Would there be a list of, you're going to play this song, you'll play this song, you'll play this song, you'll play this song?
而且，艾达，当你直播时，你面前真的会有什么吗？会有一份清单，你会播放这首歌，你会播放这首歌，你会播放这首歌，你会播放这首歌吗？
Yeah, it's basically a list. It's a list that says exactly what song comes at what time.
是的，它基本上是一个清单。这是一个说明什么时间播放什么歌的清单。
So then, what's the pleasure of being a DJ? What is the thing that you're doing yourself? Somebody else has chosen the songs and all of that.
那么，当DJ有什么乐趣呢？你自己在做什么？别人已经选择了歌曲和所有那些东西。
I don't know why people become DJs. But I don't think that they look at the room like a really big phone or something really vital or exciting or alive, but more like they look at it like a room.
我不知道人们为什么成为DJ。但我认为他们并不把这个房间看作一个非常大的电话或者某种非常重要、刺激或活着的东西，而更像是把它看作一个房间。
You look at the radio station like a really big telephone?
你把电台看作一个非常大的电话？
Yeah. Yeah, I thought of it as a really big phone. And it was a magic room. It was just the most vital room. And I really, really liked the listeners. All my phones lit up the whole show, and I just basically talked to people. And I'd talk about what people were doing at work. I'd talk about what they were eating at lunch. People would send me pictures of what they did. And it was this community. And if it was hot and people were working on roofs, I'd have them call up and talk about how hot they were and who's the hottest. And I shouted out songs.
是的。是的，我把它想作一个非常大的电话。这是一个神奇的房间。它只是最重要的房间。我真的很喜欢听众。我所有的电话在整个节目中都亮着，我基本上只是和人交谈。我会谈论人们在工作中做什么。我会谈论他们午餐吃什么。人们会给我发他们做的事情的照片。这是一个社区。如果天气很热，人们在屋顶上干活，我会让他们打来电话，谈谈他们有多热，谁是最热的。我为歌曲大声疾呼。
I know it sounds really hokey or stupid or whatever, but you were just making somebody's day. And I can't tell you how much I loved that. That's what, I think, breaks my heart the most is I miss that like you wouldn't believe.
我知道这听起来很俗气或愚蠢或无论什么，但你只是让某人的一天变得美好。我无法告诉你我有多爱那个。我想，这对我来说最心碎的是，我错过它，你不会相信。
It's so weird. It's like you were betrayed by radio itself.
这太奇怪了。感觉就像你被广播本身背叛了一样。
I just so don't want to sound like a bitter person. And there aren't very many people, if anybody, that understands what I've gone through, which is, I was saying, it's just like an open wound. Or I am just so heartbroken. This is something that I love so much. And I just don't think that it exists. It's like being in love with somebody that you've never met. It's like some kind of strange situation where I just love this thing, and I don't see it anywhere.
我只是不想听起来像个痛苦的人。没有很多人，如果有人的话，理解我经历了什么，也就是，我刚才说的，它就像一个开放的伤口。或者我只是如此心碎。这是我非常爱的东西。我只是不认为它存在。这就像爱上了一个你从未见过的人。这就像某种奇怪的情况，我只是爱这个东西，而在任何地方都看不到它。
So what are you doing now?
那么你现在在做什么？
Now? Oh, god. Well, actually, I've been doing a lot of cool things, like being in a band. And I've been writing a lot. But the real reality of it is that I ran out of money. So I'm answering phones, and I waitressed for a while.
现在？噢，天哪。嗯，其实，我一直在做很多酷的事情，比如在乐队里。我一直在写很多东西。但真正的现实是我的钱花光了。所以我接电话，我做了很长一段时间的服务员。
And do you listen to the radio on your job?
你在工作时收听广播吗？
I actually tuned into some internet stations. There was a station that I really liked in Calgary that was-- they didn't even play good music, but the people just seemed real.
我其实调入了一些互联网电台。有一个我在卡尔加里真正喜欢的电台，那是——他们甚至不播放好音乐，但人看起来很真实。
Wait, you got onto the internet, and you had to search on the internet for a radio station in Calgary?
等等，你上了互联网，你不得不在互联网上搜索卡尔加里的广播电台？
I actually went all over every single thing that they put on Yahoo. And I listened to every single station that existed.
我实际上找遍了他们在Yahoo上放的所有东西。我听了每一个存在的电台。
Until you found one that you could stand? Like, there was nothing in the metropolitan or tri-state area on the actual radio? You literally had to pull in a station from another country.
直到你找到一个你能忍受的？就像，在市区或三州地区实际的广播里没有任何东西？你真的不得不从另一个国家拉进一个台。
Participating with sister stations KEX Portland, WKRC Cincinnati, and--
参与姊妹电台KEX波特兰，WKRC辛辛那提，以及——
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
[DRINK POURING]
[饮料倒入声]
[GULPING]
[吞咽声]
[RADIO TUNING]
[收音机调频声]
Let's address the issues on the ground that affect the daily lives of the people, people who are being killed or kidnapped or tortured. All of these problems--
让我们解决地面上影响人民日常生活的议题，那些正在被杀害、绑架或折磨的人。所有这些问题——
Act Four, Noble Calling. This is Jose Ramos-Horta on an international news program called Worldview that's broadcast on Chicago's public radio station. Horta is an exile from his homeland in East Timor, has spent two decades as the leading international figure denouncing the invasion of his country by Indonesia, who won the Nobel Peace Prize in 1996 for his efforts to hinder the oppression of a small people.
第四幕，“崇高的使命”。这是何塞·拉莫斯·奥尔塔在芝加哥公共广播电台播出的名为“世界观”的国际新闻节目中。奥尔塔是他家乡东帝汶的流亡者，花了二十年时间作为领先的国际人物谴责印度尼西亚对他国家的入侵，他在1996年赢得了诺贝尔和平奖，以表彰他在阻碍对他小国人民的压迫方面所做的努力。
But before his appearance on this radio program, Worldview , he confided in producer Edie Rubinowitz that someday, if peace comes to his country, he has another dream. He would like to do a radio program himself, one like Howard Stern's. He's seen Stern's movie, Private Parts , on an airplane. We reached Horta at the United Nations offices in Geneva.
但在他出现在这个广播节目“世界观”之前，他向制片人伊迪·鲁宾诺维茨吐露，总有一天，如果和平降临他的国家，他还有另一个梦想。他想自己做一个广播节目，一个像霍华德·斯特恩那样的。他在飞机上看过斯特恩的电影《私密部位》。我们在日内瓦的联合国办公室联系到了奥尔塔。
That's the kind of radio program I would do in Timor one day. I probably wouldn't copy off the hair, but his approach is really hilarious, and I enjoy listening to him when I can.
那是我总有一天会在帝汶做的广播节目。我可能不会复制那种发型，但他的方法真的很搞笑，我尽可能地喜欢听他。
So you've heard his radio show?
所以你听过他的广播节目？
Oh, yes. Yes. I heard before-- long before the film came in-- when I was in New York. A few times, I heard it on a taxi, like when you take a taxi somewhere. At first, I didn't know what the hell this is, but I noticed the taxi driver would crack up, would laugh. And then I would join in, so after that, of course, I heard it many times whenever I could, yes.
噢，是的。是的。我听过以前——电影上映前很久——当我在纽约时。几次，我在出租车上听到，就像当你乘出租车到某处时。起初，我不知道这到底是什么，但我注意到出租车司机笑得前仰后合。然后我就加入进来，所以在那之后，当然，我尽可能多次地听它，是的。
Let me play you a little clip from the Howard Stern Show, OK?
让我给你放一小段霍华德·斯特恩节目的剪辑，好吗？
Yeah.
好的。
All right, here we go. This is a clip, he's talking about Arnold Schwarzenegger.
好的，我们开始吧。这是一个剪辑，他在谈论阿诺德·施瓦辛格。
So I said, Fred, let's go chase Arnold into the bathroom and tell him how great we think it is that he's doing Conan The Barbarian . We went in there and he's like, "What?" [FART NOISES] "Hey, boys." [FART NOISES] "Hey, boys, please. Thank you so much for nice compliment, but please." [FART NOISES]
所以我说，弗雷德，让我们去追阿诺德到浴室，告诉他我们认为他做《野蛮人柯南》有多棒。我们进去，他就像，“什么？”[放屁声]“嘿，伙计们。”[放屁声]“嘿，伙计们，请。非常感谢你的好评，但请。”[放屁声]
"Sorry to bother you, Arnold." "That's OK, boys."
“对不起打扰你，阿诺德。”“没关系，伙计们。”
Yeah. Something tells me he gets a little thing on the side going with some girls.
是的。有什么东西告诉我他会在旁边和一些女孩搞点小动作。
Oh, here we go.
噢，我们开始吧。
I'm tellling you.
我告诉你。
"Meet me in my trailer."
“在我的拖车里见我。”
"Jamie Lee, that was a good strip."
“杰米·李，那是一次很棒的脱衣舞。”
"That was very nice. Now, let's go practice in private. Come here, Rosanne."
“那非常好。现在，让我们去私下练习。过来，罗珊。”
So can you imagine that your own radio program in East Timor would go in this kind of direction?
所以你能想象你在东帝汶自己的广播节目会朝着这个方向发展吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, I don't know whether I can afford to be exactly like that. Well, they would get me off the air right away. But it is entertaining.
嗯，我不知道我是否能负担得起那样。嗯，他们会立刻把我赶下广播。但它很有娱乐性。
When you imagine what you'd like to do on your radio show, what would you like to do?
当你想象你想在你的广播节目里做什么时，你想做什么？
The kind of program, the kind of show that would not take people too seriously, like government leaders, politicians.
那种不会把人看得太严肃，像政府领导人、政治家那样的节目。
When you describe it that way, it makes it sound like you'd have mostly a political show. You saw in Howard Stern's movie, Private Parts , he has, like, naked ladies in the studio. Would you do that?
当你那样描述它时，听起来像你主要是政治节目。你在霍华德·斯特恩的电影《私密部位》里看到，他在演播室里有赤身裸体的女士。你会那样做吗？
In our society, in our country, no, I couldn't do that. I don't think you'd find too many women in the Third World that would do that. You have to take into consideration that in certain countries, there are certain things that people are not yet prepared to listen. For instance, if I were to talk about sex the same way Howard Stern Show talks, the bishop would excommunicate me right away.
在我们的社会，在我们的国家，不，我不能那样做。我认为你在第三世界找不到太多会那样做的女性。你必须考虑到在某些国家，有些东西人们还没有准备好去听。例如，如果我像霍华德·斯特恩节目谈论性那样谈论性，主教立刻就会把我逐出教会。
Yes, and I should say, you won the Nobel Peace Prize-- it was a co-award, you and an archbishop.
是的，我应该说，你赢得了诺贝尔和平奖——这是一个共同奖项，你和一位大主教。
Yeah. Bishop Carlos Filipe Ximenes Belo is an outstanding, courageous individual. And I don't think he would appreciate very much if I were to have a radio program exactly similar to Howard Stern when it comes to discussing sex.
是的。卡洛斯·费利佩·希门尼斯·贝洛主教是一位杰出、勇敢的个人。而且我不认为如果我在谈论性时有一个与霍华德·斯特恩完全相似的广播节目，他会非常欣赏。
And let me ask you to explain, what's so appealing to you about Howard Stern?
让我请你解释一下，霍华德·斯特恩对你有什么吸引力？
Well, he challenges all the hypocrisy, the snobism, the double standards. He says things, he does things that most people would want to do and to say but that they don't dare.
嗯，他挑战所有的虚伪、势利、双重标准。他说一些事情，他做一些事情，大多数人想做和想说但不敢做的事情。
You know, when you describe his program the way you do, it sounds that, in a way, it's almost a diplomat's dream. A diplomat can't usually say exactly what's on their mind, and here, you have a radio personality who gets to say exactly what he wants.
你知道，当你那样描述他的节目时，听起来在某种程度上，这几乎是外交官的梦想。外交官通常不能说出他们脑子里的想法，在这里，你有一个广播人物，他可以确切地说出他想要的。
Exactly. Many diplomats feel like I do. You get frustrated with all this posturing at the United Nations. And sometimes, I lose my temper and I tell some people what I actually think of them. And if I were not constrained by the delicate work I do, if I were to have my own radio program, I tell you, I would be almost exactly like Howard Stern.
正是如此。许多外交官和我一样。你对联合国所有的姿态感到沮丧。有时，我失去耐心，我告诉一些人我实际上是怎么看他们的。如果我没有被我所做的微妙工作所束缚，如果我有自己的广播节目，我告诉你，我会几乎和霍华德·斯特恩一模一样。
We don't believe you. Flat out don't--
我们不相信你。直接不——
I don't really care what you believe.
我真的不在乎你相信什么。
I don't believe it.
我不相信。
I think that Mark has a radar in his pants for money.
我认为马克裤子里有一个找钱的雷达。
Yep.
没错。
Do you think there are many members of the diplomatic corps who listen to Howard Stern and are fans?
你认为有很多听霍华德·斯特恩并是粉丝的外交团成员吗？
Oh, yes, yes. People have fun. They enjoy it. Most of them feel, well, that's exactly what I would like to say myself.
噢，是的，是的。人们很有趣。他们享受它。他们中的大多数人觉得，嗯，那正是我想对自己说的话。
And if only I could have a job where I were able to speak honestly like this.
如果我能有一份工作，我能够像这样诚实地说话。
Exactly. Yes, yes.
正是如此。是的，是的。
Now, over the last few weeks, knowing that we were going to do this interview, we've been trying to arrange to get you onto The Howard Stern Show so you could take a look firsthand at your potential new career. And we haven't been successful so far. And I understand that at one point, you were in contact with them. You called them up.
现在，在过去的几周里，知道我们将要进行这次采访，我们一直试图安排你上霍华德·斯特恩秀，这样你就可以第一手看看你潜在的新职业。但到目前为止我们还没成功。我知道有一次，你和他们联系过。你打电话给他们。
Yeah.
是的。
Can you tell me what happened?
你能告诉我发生了什么吗？
Well, first, the lady had no idea what I was talking about. I told her East Timor. She said, East what? She probably thought I was calling from the East Side in New York. After, I tried to explain-- she even didn't know what the Nobel Peace Prize is all about.
嗯，首先，那位女士根本不知道我在说什么。我告诉她东帝汶。她说，东什么？她可能以为我从纽约的东区打来。之后，我试图解释——她甚至不知道诺贝尔和平奖是什么。
She had never heard of the Nobel Peace Prize?
她从没听说过诺贝尔和平奖？
No. and then she pass on to the editors or the producer, whoever. And they say they don't know what you're talking about.
不。然后她转接给编辑或制片人，不管是谁。他们说他们不知道你在说什么。
Yeah. I'm going to play you one more clip. This is also from The Howard Stern Show.
是的。我要再给你放一个剪辑。这还是来自霍华德·斯特恩秀。
Morning, Howard.
早上好，霍华德。
Right.
好的。
I'm interested in the porno cruise contest.
我对色情游轮比赛感兴趣。
All right, listen. This is the ultimate prize. It's a porno cruise. It's like 70 hot chicks who are going to be naked the entire time, filming porno. They're going to be poolside. It's a cruise, a legitimate cruise, and we've got two tickets to give away.
好的，听着。这是终极奖品。这是一个色情游轮。大约有70个火辣的妞，她们在整个过程中会赤身裸体，拍摄色情片。她们会在泳池边。这是一个游轮，一个合法的游轮，我们有两个票要送出去。
In other words, they're having a cruise, and it's going to be all porno actresses. And they're giving away tickets to it.
换句话说，他们有一个游轮，全部都是色情女演员。他们在送出票。
But that again, is a joke, no?
但那再一次，是一个笑话，不是吗？
No, I think it's real.
不，我认为它是真的。
It's real?
它是真的？
I think it's real.
我认为它是真的。
Well, OK, if it's a joke to joke people, I would. Many, many years ago, when I was a journalist back in Timor, on April Fools Day, I ran a story saying that a Swedish cruise vessel had ran aground not far from the capital, and there were many blond, nice, Swedish women around. And I tell you, everybody, including some very respectable men, they all rushed there. And all there was when they got there, there I was, waiting for them. There was no boat, no Swedish women.
嗯，好的，如果是为了开玩笑而开玩笑，我会的。很多很多年前，当我在帝汶当记者时，在愚人节，我写了一个故事说一艘瑞典游轮在离首都不远的地方搁浅了，周围有很多金发、漂亮、瑞典女人。而且我告诉你，每个人，包括一些非常受人尊敬的人，他们全都冲向那里。而且当他们到达那里时，只有我，在等着他们。没有船，没有瑞典女人。
You were ahead of your time.
你领先于你的时代。
Thank you.
谢谢。
In a certain way-- you're trying to get freedom for your homeland-- do you view this kind of speech, which, I have to say, Howard Stern is often criticized here in the States for the things he says and the way he is. Do you view this as being, in a certain way, what freedom is all about?
以某种方式——你正在为你的祖国争取自由——你认为这种言论，我不得不说，霍华德·斯特恩在美国经常因为他说的话和他做人的方式受到批评。你认为这是，以某种方式，自由的全部吗？
Yes, obviously, that is freedom. It is irreverent, but it is freedom. It is honesty. And that's why it is so popular and many people hate him because of that. But he should, in fact, receive a medal of freedom for what he's doing.
是的，显然，那是自由。它是不敬的，但它是自由。它是诚实。这就是为什么它如此受欢迎，很多人因此恨他。但他应该，实际上，因为他所做的事情获得一枚自由奖章。
Jose Ramos-Horta in Geneva.
何塞·拉莫斯·奥尔塔在日内瓦。
Well, our hundredth addition of This American Life was produced by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and [? Sahini ?] Davenport.
嗯，我们第一百期的《美国生活》是由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作的，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克，资深编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。劳拉·多格特和[萨希尼？]达文波特的制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our 100 shows, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago. 312-832-3380. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买此节目或我们100个节目中任何一个的磁带，请致电我们这里芝加哥的WBEZ。312-832-3380。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who has issued new orders for how I'm supposed to do the show from now on.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他已经发布了关于我从现在起应该如何做节目的新命令。
"Could you sound more, I don't know, like a dominatrix?"
“你能听起来更，我不知道，像个女施虐狂吗？”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。